so we are over here to see Mount Fuji
and of course it's foggy as hell that we
can't see anything out here
but we came for
oh no and we gotta go on a cognitive to
which I was really excited for right now
I saw it hi and the Oscar goes to David
fell for being a bad [ __ ] so the laser
pointers you know the battery decided
that's exactly what my penis looks like
right now I can't feel anything
I like being toasted of a look if I was
really cold I would have zipped up my
jacket a long time ago but I did it I
just had this really big step but my
hands are freezing though my hands are
like ice you have to touch it
ice they're warm compared to my head I
don't like with my penis but what what
what my penis feel like a little marble
stick
how come you don't eat this this is the
best part
people don't understand oh good the
shrimp head am I missing these shrimp
heads on there the [ __ ] he just
everybody always throws away the shrimp
it but they don't realize this is the
best part of the shrimp it has the most
flavor I don't know how you forget
especially when you deep fry it and it
has like the head fat in it delicious
everything is tiny in Japan I think
there's whole country's going to starve
me to death
look at this [ __ ] who the hell is this
going to quench this is my hand this is
the cup what the know what this is what
he didn't know I was here people here
you see sorry two people for hitting and
bumping into them he's like I'm just a
breathin
this is interesting I will get a coin
purse too but I found out that I'm
looking [ __ ] with one so and also the
other men's of JK [ __ ]
well you just pop it in which makes
sense please come into the conversation
it's okay sir it's okay sir that's funny
because that mustache is coming real
nice back to the conversation before it
was interrupted by Mexican giant this we
broke yeah it's like it come on junior I
think we're just here to see it right
mega city kid
Wow tired trip has been good you can at
least do this David David elbow we went
wrong oh I hope you all have this you
can do nothing for me child
I don't we're not ready what we're
getting a little small it is you're
gonna be the only one that gets on but
listen I don't understand who that's
gonna all gone my head I hurt my head
are they scared because I have a deathly
fear of hi David is that they're not
look stable it's dude look at how many
tires on that [ __ ] Excel Speedway look
at all the children in there and that's
how done they are cuz they're young
there's nothing to worry about guys
there's big metal wires there's no wire
that's the only one thing that's holding
what it's very very strong like that one
thing snaps we're all God my ass is
sledding is imagine if the wire does not
fall of the wire snaps and everybody
falls out the first thing I do is I
think about Mike Myers in that one movie
where they were both falling off the
building and they grabbed the person
from them did you're going first
you know this is very anticlimactic but
because of our tour being so [ __ ] today
that this is pretty exciting this is
highlighting this is the highlight
yeah it's still better because we
haven't done good guy
we're I mean this is a rest day this is
like being stuck in a bus but now we're
stuck in a gondola and it's mother I did
the funny thing about that lady was she
was just sitting there going like okay
so today we are not going to do [ __ ]
yeah lay to us but we won't be doing all
day usually you know we are going to the
lake but today because of the weather is
not permit usually there's so much money
falling from the sky I gotta be there
you know it's not the permit